a tweet that we posted yesterday that
got plenty of traction and I have no
idea whether or not there's any truth to
this but when a guy who is a host on
WFAN radio in New York one of the most
popular local radio stations in the
entire country and the place where Odell
Beckham jr. started his career from 2014
through 2018 when this guy goes on the
air mark my lusus and then takes to
Twitter and says the same thing I have
to at least pay attention to it and
here's the tweet that got a lot of
people riled up yesterday sources told
me that the Browns and the Vikings are
in discussions on a trade that would
send Odell Beckham jr. to the Vikings
for a second and fifth round pick next
year trade is not done but the deal is
being discussed and look who the hell
knows whether or not the Browns are
inclined to trade Odell Beckham jr. a
guy they just picked up from the Giants
a year ago who knows whether or not the
Vikings are inclined to try to add him I
I'm waiting for the statement from Rick
Spielman Chris that ohto Beckham jr. is
a Cleveland Brown just like he told us
in February Stefon Diggs as a Minnesota
Viking I mean no one's gonna come out
and admit there's anything to this until
it's done if it ever happens so it's
almost impossible to really peel the
onion if there is anything to it and if
there isn't anything to it the stuff
people say is gonna be no different than
what they say if there is something to
it so we're just kind of stuck here to
sit and wait to see whether it happens
or whether it doesn't yeah well you're
right we are all right so two things
right off the bat I know Marc malusi's
I've worked with them before the 8a the
boosts they call them up here I mean
you're right first off the the place in
which he works at this is not like an
attention-seeker you know type of radio
host either I would have think he
thought he got this from somebody
credible you know this is not a guy
that's careless and in nature that way
at all so I think that deserves some
merit let alone Mike you know again
here's just I don't know anything either
about the situation I sent out text
messages through a few people that
you know I thought would be have some
inside knowledge on something like this
going down and I got crickets back I
mean not no responses so when I usually
get that type of response that usually
makes me believe that something is going
on that there is talks and nobody wants
to kind of let it out quite yet and yes
I mean I think if the Vikings saw all
this news yesterday and everything like
that they might have released a tweet or
some sort of statement saying that's not
going to happen but they didn't do that
either so yes I have no inside knowledge
right now but it's very interesting and
you know it's let's get into the
nitty-gritty as far as whether we think
it makes sense for both teams well from
the Vikings perspective they don't have
a whole lot of CAP space although they
have managed to add some by virtue of
restructurings of contracts like Kirk
Cousins that freed up ten million
dollars and they moved on from guys they
traded Stefon Diggs although that didn't
free up a lot of net cap space because
they took a cap hit by moving him yes
they avoid his salary but that's offset
by the cap charge I don't see the
Vikings happily adding 14 million
dollars in base salary to their overall
cap picture this year especially when
you consider this Chris
odo Beckham juniors gonna want a new
contract at some point last year when he
got traded to the Browns there were some
rumblings that he wanted a new deal and
it never happened
he gets traded again he may want a new
deal this time and how are the Vikings
gonna do that how are they going to be
able to afford that when they have so
much other money allocated to positions
like that so I just think dollars and
cents I thought your dog didn't bark I
thought from a dollars and cents
standpoint and a cap standpoint it's a
difficult move for the Vikings to pull
off and that's before we even get to do
they want the potential headache that
obj brings to the team if he's not
getting the football as much as he wants
it well yeah I hear you you're right I
mean if they make that type of trade
well first off with Odell Beckham jr.
last year we just assumed really that he
might ask for a new contract because of
what Antonio Brown had done in his
situation we thought maybe that's what
was going to go down and how Antonio
Brown had so much you know force of
nature to make his
train we thought Odell Beckham jr. might
be able to do the same type of thing now
it's very scary your right to the point
of if you do trade for Odell Beckham jr.
will he ask for more money you're gonna
need somewhat of a wink-wink handshake
with him and his agent to say no we
won't even go down that road you know
for at least two years or anything like
that you know you're you're you're
you're connecting dots between hey
Stefon Diggs being a little bit of a
diva receiver do they really want to
deal with one with Adele Beckham jr. you
know who hasn't had the cleanest history
as far as being a distraction or non
distraction to his football team like I
get that you're right I mean yes I don't
know did the Vikings want to deal with
that yeah so that I endured that I don't
know yet Mike but what I will say there
is this you know I'm sure the Vikings
are evaluating the draft boards a little
bit and what they might get there in the
mid 20s where they pick and they realize
that they have other rub holes on their
roster to fill and a trade for a wide
receiver right now might just take one
of those holes away so now they can use
that traffic for another position let
alone I think Odell Beckham jr. on the
Minnesota Vikings makes a lot of sense
X's and O's wise well and listen I agree
with you I was on with Paul Allen the
voice of the Vikings earlier this week
and we were talking about receivers in
the draft and I said whatever they do
they need somebody who can take the top
off the defense somebody who can keep
the safeties honest somebody who can
unclog the middle of that second level
for when Dalvin cook busts through it on
a running play you don't want to have an
eighth or ninth man cheating up into the
box to stop him before he turns it into
a 22 25 yard gain and if you've got odo
Beckham jr. you've got that threat and
whether it's going deep and drawing the
coverage deep or getting that slant pass
and just exploding past everyone you're
going to have to account for him
maybe even more than you had to account
for Stefon Diggs all due respect to
Stefon Diggs so I agree with you from
that perspective if you can get Odell
Beckham jr. to buy in when you couldn't
get Stefon Diggs to buy into the fact
that some weeks we're going to run the
ball 42
and pass it ten times other weeks the
ball is going to be in the air a lot it
just depends week in and week out do you
have the personalities to get Odell
Beckham jr.
to accept that and not have this
constant week after week after week
narrative of how do we get the ball to
obj we got to get the ball to obj and
the Vikings franchise has been down that
road before with Randy Moss and the
stupid Randy ratio
you can't force the ball to one player
in the passing game you have to throw it
to the open man yeah here's the reality
diff Dalvin cook surrounding the ball
like he did last year there will be
plenty of plays when Odell Beckham jr.
is open we see Kirk Cousins do the
little bootleg and the the roll out and
the play action and Beckham gets open
and Cousins is gonna get him the ball
yeah I mean yeah I mean you're right on
all okay so yes he's a lightning rod
that way so you gotta feel comfortable
with yes if you bring Odell Beckham jr.
in people are gonna put him under a
microscope how many times have you
thrown the ball are you getting it to
him enough oh if he didn't get it enough
one week the questions gonna come right
away are you happy here you know you're
not getting the ball as much as you'd
like so you know there certainly is that
aspect of having to deal with Odell
Beckham jr. because he's you know
arguably one of the two or three most
famous guys in the NFL right now on the
big stage of things now to the football
aspect of it Mike you made a lot of good
points I totally agree with you you know
first off I've heard a lot of people say
but why would the Vikings want to do
this there are a running football team
well you said it yes this is a team that
wants to play two running backs one
tight end two wide receivers and within
that okay yes we know they want to run
the football and a guy like Odell
Beckham jr. hey I know his stats weren't
real sexy last year but man did he help
out that Cleveland offense and made
everybody else look better even not
being a hundred percent healthy people
give him unbelievable attention and it
is no disrespect to Stefon Diggs whose
phenomenal but he's not Odell Beckham
jr. Odell Beckham jr. is a game changer
he's a guy that teams really go
I'm not so sure I ever want to leave my
corner one-on-one with this guy we
almost have to double them every time
it's a passing situation and to what you
said mike is spot on so now okay we want
to run the ball with Dalvin cook
oh there's Odell Beckham jr. one side
they're stealing to the other side you
can have a concept built built in the
offense for a guy like feeling to run
some intricate route but on the other
side you got Odell and you just go okay
if they got two safeties back all right
we just gonna run the ball to that side
and because they're gonna be short in
the in the box as far as being able to
stop people in between the tackles
oh it's man-to-man hey we like Odell
man-to-man against anybody you know
that's really the style of football that
Minnesota showed they want a pie last
year it's a little simple and old-school
but effective nonetheless especially
when you have the right talent to make
it work a point made by our producer
Pete demo lightest Stefon Diggs had 60%
of the targets in 2018 that he had in
2018 but he had a career high in
receiving yards and eleven hundred and
thirty look you get open and if Cousins
has time he's getting you the ball and
and a couple other points on this I mean
this is something we could come at from
every possible yes there's a lot of
question here's the thing why would it
be that someone in New York knows about
this here's how I think and people get
nervous when we speculate on sources but
I think when something like this comes
out where you look at it and say how did
that happen well if the Vikings are
doing their homework on Eldo Beckham jr.
properly they're talking to the Giants
right at some point yeah you're calling
up the Giants at some point somebody
with the Giants catches wind of this
interest by the Vikings in Odell Beckham
jr. and starts to get maybe some of the
other details and somebody in the New
York media hears about it right what the
Giants have no reason to keep this quiet
the Giants would like to create chaos
the giant bear the Browns to have an
upset Odell Beckham jr. who's even
saltier than he was last year because
they're talking about trading him they
want to be able to say we did the right
thing when we moved Odell Beckham jr. so
if they can throw a wrench into the
gears so be it so
it's not all that ridiculous to connect
the dots no it's not I got out and and I
had this kind of the same experience you
had where I I tried to you know you
contact people and you try to get and
it's like something's not right here
you know like it's just one of those
yeah and and especially because you're
gonna and that's the thing if there was
absolutely positively nothing to it
whatsoever
the Browns would be sure Browns when it
came you have to because otherwise you
lose this guy you know no ya failed
their uniforms an hour before the unveil
the uniforms this came out you got to
throw water on this immediately if
there's nothing to it
if there's something to it that's a
different analysis well Mike I mean
first off I think you're a master at
connecting dots you really are you prove
that to me over the last three years I'm
working together I know I'm like you
know I might not have a black belt in
connecting dots but I got like what's
the next one down the brown belt you
know I'm gonna brown belt I don't even
know but either way I think that's the
big point Mike that's where I was in a
go if this wasn't real you're Cleveland
you shut this up yesterday you don't
want to deal with this and have this
talk and now okay Odell Beckham jr. is
gonna have to hear about this if he
doesn't get traded this is gonna be the
number one conversation to start
Cleveland Browns training camp and also
I'll just say this Mike you know I don't
know why would you want to get rid of
Odell Beckham jr. right now if you're
the Cleveland Browns I mean you know
again unless he's more of a pain in the
butt that I realized behind the scenes
you know I again my through my football
evaluation I know his stats won't look
as good as what we're accustomed to but
man did he do a lot of good for that
offense last year because of the
attention he received from just about
every defense he played week after week
and he wasn't a hundred percent and if
I'm Cleveland and I got Baker Mayfield
and this team right now that has plenty
of salary cap space and really could be
a team where we go oh my gosh they're
one of the best teams in the AFC this
year because they have that type of
talent I just
wouldn't trade Odell Beckham jr. unless
I got some crazy offer that just blew my
doors off
yeah two and a five next year isn't
what's going to do it that no it's not
gonna do it but but who knows who knows
look I think there's something there
just based on everything I've seen in a
herd and what we're talking about who
knows whether or not it goes anywhere
but I feel like there's a little flicker
and and we'll see if that flicker grows
over the course of the next week the
draft is coming up obviously a week from
today
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports